You may have seen cotton candy
dissolving in water before,
maybe from us
on our channel before,
and maybe from a video
of a raccoon,
who was handed as a treat.
But today, we want
to find out just
how much cotton candy you
can dissolve into water.
[Music]
Guys, cotton candy.
Cotton candy is great.
Some place is
called candy floss,
>> Fairy floss.
>> or fairy floss.
Few names.
Lots of different
things to call it.
But you know it, you love it.
It's super fine thin strands of
sugar in a big old puffy ball,
and it's delicious.
We should make some.
We should make a lot.
We should make so much.
Before we get to making our
giant batches of cotton candy,
which is coming
in this full-size
industrial cotton candy machine,
we do have a few other things
we want to learn and try.
Here's the basic idea.
We are going to explore the hows
and whys of cotton candy,
starting with how it
was originally made,
scaling it up
to an industrial-sized machine,
and then seeing just how much
we could dissolve into water.
Now, the first machine was made
by a dentist, I believe?
But some people think it
actually dated back all the way
to Italy in the 15th century.
So we're going to start with
some of those original styles,
and scale it up from there.
1 cup of sugar.
1 tablespoon of water,
and that's it.
Those are the ingredients
for super basic candy floss.
Now, we're just going to stir
the sugar in the hot water
until it all dissolves.
So we've let our sugar
caramelized on the stove,
and now you can see
that we're getting
these really nice strings,
and this is what we want.
So what we're going
to be doing is wait
until it cools
just a little bit,
and then we're going
to be taking our forks,
dragging them back and forth
over the top of our pot,
and it's actually going to help
us make some candy floss.
But make sure
if you're doing this
with somebody else,
that they're not
standing in the way.
You don't want
to get hit with this.
Burnt sugar.
I have a scar on my arm from
doing a video with burnt sugar.
If you remember
the candy Iron Man helmet,
I dripped some Sugar on my arm
while I was doing that.
Got a little scar
right there from it.
[Music]
Like Spider-Man,
but sugar Spider-Man.
We have a lot.
This is actually really cool.
Look at this.
Okay, so we're not,
like it was saying
we're not the best.
You can see that we've got
these little drips everywhere,
but it's actually really pretty.
So then, you can like,
if you wanted to put this
on a top of something,
you can like wind
it into a nest,
and that's just a really
pretty, like decoration.
So original candy floss.
We got the OG candy.
I don't even know if you
can call this cotton candy.
Candy floss kind of works
because it's thin strings,
but it's not as fine as you get
with an industrial machine.
And so, it's more like--
It actually looks
a lot like fiberglass.
I'm kind of having a hard time
like mentally getting
through putting it in my mouth,
>> but it's delicious.
>> Floss works.
[Music]
That was really good.
Taste like sugar,
and then the little drips
that we have that probably
shouldn't be in there are just
like little crunchy bits.
Homemade version with a fork,
and professional version
with the big fancy machine.
So you can see this has
a lot finer strings.
In fact, you can't even
really see individual strands.
Because they're so fine,
it really has turned
into a cotton like consistency.
This is very very thin,
but compared to the stuff
that comes out of the machine,
it's not the same.
Oh, no.
This stuff in the
pot is caramelizing
and crystallizing already,
and I put a blob of it my mouth,
and now my teeth
are stuck together?
And they're going to be
like that forever.
I did this to myself.
Yeah.
We've moved outside,
and there's a very
good reason for that.
You can probably see...
Well, maybe you can see,
as it's starting
to heat up already,
it starts throwing
little wisps of sugar.
It makes a huge mess.
That doesn't stop.
Okay, new plan.
It's not going to be
how much cotton candy we
can dissolve in water.
It's going to be how much Nate
can dissolve in his stomach.
[Music]
No!
Our tower's coming
along beautifully,
but unfortunately,
we just had a little bit
more wind picking up,
and it just got
gusted, and its...
It collapsed a little bit.
What from here to here.
Very unfortunate.
But we do still have
a giant mound of cotton candy.
[Music]
Now, we're going to time-lapse
us eating all this cotton candy.
No, we're not.
Not gonna happen.
That's too much.
I'll die.
[Music]
So let's start grabbing pieces
that are approximately
the same size.
I started with two piles.
>> So I'm just going to--
>> I was gonna do the same.
Do you think we can fit one
of these whole piles
in one cup of water?
I'm just gonna stick
a pile in it,
and see if we can go from there.
These two, I broke,
these were just individual
pieces I broke in half.
This is gonna be fine.
This is, this is fine.
Oh, this is
my new favorite game.
[Music]
Doesn't seem to be slowing
down once you hit--
No.
Okay, that was
exactly that much.
So let's start
breaking up some more.
So, let's take this piece,
and keep this one,
and dissolve that one.
Keep that one,
dissolve that one.
Is it slowing down at all?
Maybe a little.
Kind of starting to get
off the sides a little bit.
[Music]
This has been like, what?
30 cotton candy.
It's hard to tell.
Yeah, this is a lot of sugar.
We can tell you that much.
Oh, yeah, there it is.
This is what's happening now.
So while it is still
melting the cotton candy,
it's not really dissolving
into the water anymore.
So I'd say we
probably hit our limit,
and possibly even gone past it.
All of that is in this.
This much cotton candy.
In fact, this has,
as we've been
like tearing it apart,
>> and--
>> It's been compressing.
Yeah, when you grab a piece,
and you squeeze it
to tear it apart,
and you really
squish part of it,
and so you end up with slightly
more condensed cotton candy.
So more than this much
cotton candy has fit
into this single cup of water.
This is for science.
[Music]
Oh.
I actually think it smells more
like cooking sugar,
like when we were making
the other kind of,
like the caramel on the stove?
I think it smells
kind of like that.
It does.
It almost taste...
Definitely not as
runny as water.
Look at that.
It looks more like oil.
It tastes a little
burnt as a warning.
I don't know why.
We didn't burn our cotton candy,
so that's a little confusing.
That was like a taste.
Yeah.
Now, do you understand
what I went through?
It's much thicker
than I thought it
was going to be
while drinking it.
That much sugar,
that's perfectly compressed.
Uncompressed as you
would find it,
you know pouring out of a bag,
normal white sugar.
That's about how much
we're looking at right there.
Maybe even a little bit more,
and this is actually
about how much sugar goes
into a two-liter bottle of soda.
You ever finish off
a two-liter bottle of soda,
that's what you're drinking.
Let's melt a little
bit more of it.
There's another thing
I want to try.
I want to see what it looks
like to melt it over steam.
[Music]
As you can see, a cone of
cotton candy would not survive long
over a steaming pot.
[Music]
Next test, fire.
We're going to see what happens.
We know we can melt sugar,
sugar will melt.
It'll caramelize, it will burn.
But we haven't tried
it on cotton candy.
[Music]
This is awesome.
It's like tunneled through it.
[Music]
It's almost like a lime
Jolly Rancher now.
That's so good.
[Music]
All right.
I think it's competition time.
What's the rules?
Throw the most cotton candy
into the fish tank.
Go.
All right.
That's too easy.
We need to play horse.
[Music]
No.
Come on, me.
There.
No.
I'm just gonna--
Oh.
Oh, denied.
Blocked.
Yes.
[Music]
>> That's gross.
>> That's really cool though.
I can't--
Let's take like
yeah big old blobs at once.
Well.
1, 2, 3.
[Music]
Oh, no, that's so cool.
The quickest way to get rid
of cotton candy.
[Music]
I literally can't fill it
fast enough to get it all.
It's gone.
And it's gone.
Holy cow.
That was like...
This was a pile,
the volume of an adult person.
Two adult people when we began.
When we began,
it was more than
two adult people.
Yeah, it was higher
than we were sitting down.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top,
it's going to take you
to our last video.
You should go watch that.
The other box is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
You should check
that one out too.
If you are not subscribed,
you gotta hit this bomb
to get in the club.
That way, you're never going
to miss out on a cool video.
Also, don't forget
to ring that bell.
We'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.